the packers potentially trying to get
better
we've tried to broker the deal that
would send amari cooper from dallas to
green bay but
a little too rich for the green green
bay blood
and salary cap how about will fuller
instead aaron
reese of the athletic reported yesterday
that there are teams talking to the
texans about will fuller first round
draft pick back in 2016.
in his option year at 10 million plus no
sign of an extension
why not get exactly for him and the
green bay packers reportedly one of the
interested teams there would be a
reunion there matt laflore with the
quarterbacks coach at notre dame in 2014
one of the three years that fuller
was playing for the fighting irish so
that's something to keep an eye because
again today's the day
for anyone that wants the guy available
for next week's game week nine
yeah you got to get the deal done today
so he can show up and practice next
wednesday uh i mean
uh i i i mean if i'm green bay i'm i'm
doing it i'm trying to make this happen
a hundred percent he would be what would
you give for him what would you give
well you know again last year of his
contract free agency next year franchise
tag long-term deals just like emmanuel
sanders right
you got a third rounder last year for
the broncos what do you give for wilfred
well
i i've only got him for the rest of this
year he's more talented than emmanuel
sanders and more dangerous that way i
mean this is a guy that really i mean
he's scary he can go 60-yard bombs on
anybody
now but you do have an injury history
too and that's always the biggest
concern with will fuller is his
availability
when he's out there we you know we used
to say last year is he healthy oh they
are going to win
oh he's not playing well they're going
to struggle we don't know what's going
to happen
i mean that's really how he's gone
throughout his career but
you know talent wise you know again yes
he's
younger more in the prime of his career
than emmanuel sanders and certainly more
talented at this time of his career than
emmanuel sanders was last year and
that's no
disrespect to a really good player and
sanders
and then we saw the muhammad sanu so i
would think that
you'd have to probably throw a second
round pick out there maybe
maybe you get away with it with a third
round pick i i don't know
um but but either way
if i'm green bay i'm trying to make that
happen the nfc
is up for grabs you have aaron rodgers
you have a chance to go to the super
bowl this year you do
i mean listen they play seattle yeah i
know
i mean seattle's defense i don't know
they going to stop green bay in them
the only thing i look at and go is does
green bay got enough weapons
because i don't think green bay's
defense is going to stop seattle so they
need another weapon
what about with tampa bay again you know
we saw there
whoa you know i don't know you know
either you have to really improve your
defense or you have to get another
weapon on offense to get in a shootout
with brady and company
so uh i think this is probably the
quickest most realistic
fix for for green bay to take that next
step up a little bit
fuller missed nine games last year five
games the year before that
nine games the year before that six
games in
2017. his his most games played
as a rookie he appeared in 14 with 13
starts and he has a career high of 670
receiving yards so the potential has
never fully been fulfilled one of the
keys is staying healthy but i can see
why the packers are interested
the question is how do you value him by
way of trade
and how do you value him by way of
keeping him around if that's what you
decide to do all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports